♪♪♪
-Josh Brolin -- when he hosted,
Sarah Palin came on,
which was the same night
that Will Forte
first submitted "Fart Face."
-Given name is Carl, but he
likes to be called Fart Face.
-So at dress, the sketch
does terribly.
-Fart Face!
Fart Face! Fart Face!
-Oh, God, no!
-Fart Face! Fart Face!
-But it gets in.
Everyone has a sense
everyone in America is watching.
And then Josh Brolin,
he's looking up here
at the bleachers like this...
And he's just nodding at them.
And he looks at Forte and Bill
and he goes,
"Let's shut these [bleep] up."
And that was the Emmy episode.
-They're not really pranks.
We did a lot of stuff waiting
for Lorne at the read-through.
'Cause, you know,
you're always --
you're waiting a little bit
and so we sang
"Happy Birthday" for him
when it was just not
his birthday.
He was like, "Oh, good,
thank you." Yeah.
But he kind of was smiling.
I think he -- yeah.
[ Laughs ]
-There wasn't a screen test.
It was a series of auditions.
The first time I came here,
it was just Neil Levy.
Just me and Neil in his office,
and he said, "Make me laugh."
And he sat back,
and I did my shtick.
And luckily, 'cause I was
doing stand-up already --
See, I think a lot of
actors come,
somebody say, "Make me laugh,"
and you don't have an act,
it might be pretty daunting.
I did Ali, Muhammad Ali
and Howard Cosell,
and Jimmy Carter --
that's how long ago it was.
Jimmy Carter impression.
And I did Bill Cosby.
And he didn't laugh at all.
He just sat and kind of
looked at me and said,
"Thank you." And then I left.
I was like, "Oh, I guess
didn't get it."
Then a couple weeks later
they called me
and said, "Come in.
We want to see you again."
Then I went back. This time
it was two people in a room.
And they said
"Make me laugh" again,
and I did the same thing again.
And they said, "Thank you."
Then another week or two
went by,
and they called me back again,
and then I went --
it was Liz Welch, Neil Levy,
and Mike Zannella,
and he was one of
the producers on the show.
And they said,
"Make us laugh."
And I did all my stuff,
and Mike Zannella
was in the back
and he did like this --
[ Weak laugh ]
That was my big la--
That was the big laugh
of the three auditions.
-We did a sketch
called "Blockbuster"
where I played, like,
a hobo woman.
And we literally shot
all day and all night
until about 7:30 in the morning,
and then had to be back here
at noon,
so the turnaround
was horrible,
and I basically, like,
slept here
as if it was home
and then washed, like,
my hands and feet in the sink.
Like, I've mostly used
this space
to, like, recoup in some way.
I think when people think
of "SNL,"
they think of people doing coke,
and mostly it's me sitting
right here with a blanket on.
♪♪♪